BOB: Thanks for coming.
Donald Stoker is professor
of strategy and policy
at the US Naval War
College in Monterey
at the Naval
Postgraduate School.
He's the author of, or
editor of, seven books,
including a book on the Civil
War, "The Grand Design--
Strategy and the Civil War,"
which won the 2010 Fletcher
Pratt award.
So he's going to tell us about
Clausewitz, which many of you
have heard of.
The most famous
quote is, "War is
the continuation of
policy by other means."
But I think he's going
to tell us there's
more to him than
that, which is good,
because the book is
kind of hard to read.
I've tried reading Clausewitz
and didn't go too far.
So with that, let's
welcome Donald Stoker.
DONALD STOKER:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thank you, Bob.
And I thank Google
for inviting me.
It's a good opportunity for me.
And to start with my disclaimer,
because I'm a federal employee.
Everything I say is
my opinion and not
that of the United
States government
or any branch or
association thereof.
So I'm going to talk
to you just a little
bit this morning about
Carl von Clausewitz.
I teach a class-- a class
called Strategy and War--
and we talk about
Clausewitz the theorist.
And one of the things I have
to overcome with my students--
some of the students,
the mid-grade officers--
is there's a reluctance
sometimes to study theory.
And sometimes their reluctance
is with good reason.
But if they've ever
heard of Clausewitz,
or if anyone's
ever heard of him,
obviously he's the
author of "On War."
And that's certainly where
he's been most of influential.
But Clausewitz was
also a soldier,
and this is sometimes forgotten
in the discussion of his ideas
and end of his life.
And it gives him a little
bit more credibility
to some of my students, who have
often been deployed nine or 10
times to Iraq, Afghanistan,
or sundry other entertaining
places, when they realize,
yeah, this is a guy,
he's not just a theorist,
some professor like me
up there just spouting
things to them.
He's a guy who actually
had done something as well.
And to me, you can't
separate his experience
as a soldier from his
writing as a theorist,
because both things
are so intertwined.
And so Clausewitz,
again, he was a soldier,
and a soldier with an
enormous amount of experience.
He was probably
in 36-- either in
or present at least
three dozen battles.
I think it was more, but
it's difficult to decisively
determine that from the
source material I could find.
His father was a soldier.
He grew up in the
country of Prussia,
which is the country,
as you guys know,
eventually unifies Germany.
And he goes into the
army probably at age 11.
There's some argument
over his birth date.
And this is not actually
unusual for this time period.
In British Navy famously,
kids went to sea eight, nine,
10 years old.
So the child soldier has
been with us for a long time.
It's not just a
scourge we see today.
And he fights in all
five of these wars here.
And this is essentially
in some ways
an outline for some of the stuff
I'm going to talk about to you.
Because I'm going to talk
about why these things matter
for his development and
hopefully why it matters
for what he eventually gives us.
And there are several strong
influences, obviously,
in his life and influences
in writing as well.
And one of the most important is
the French Revolution in 1789,
when the French revolutionaries
revolt, overthrow the king,
eventually execute him.
And you see a situation
where, because
of the French
Revolution, you overturn
the political and military
apple carts and social apple
cart in many ways of Europe--
in a particular way, warfare.
For our purposes, it was an
important way warfare is done.
Armies go from being small,
fairly small, relatively
professional to having mass
armies fed by conscription
and fed by large
elements of the state.
And you see this
unleashing of the passion
of the citizen, the
passion of the people,
as Clausewitz himself calls
it, to harness to war,
whereas the people had
been kind of pushed aside
and war was the
realm of the army
and the king and the princes.
It becomes the role
of the people as well.
And from this French
Revolutionary experience
rises up one Clausewitz's
other influences
in many ways, this man here--
Napoleon Bonaparte-- who
becomes, because of his own
skill, the opportunity he has,
and just his brilliant
as well in co-opting
this wonderful French military
machine that develops,
becomes the master of Europe.
And you can see what
Clausewitz says about him.
Calls him "the god
of war himself,
the most determined general
the world has ever seen."
He doesn't like
Napoleon's politics,
but he admires, respects
Napoleon's military skill,
and wants to know why is this
guy so good at what he does.
Well, Clausewitz goes off to his
first war in January of 1793.
Remember, he was born in 1780.
And this campaign
is essentially one
of the first revolutionary
wars, where it's essentially
Prussia and Austria
fighting the French,
and there are some
other little countries,
smaller states involved.
And the French revolutionaries
had essentially
ended up eventually at
war with most of Europe,
to boil it down.
But he'll participate in the
siege of this city of Mainz,
and he'll help attack some
of the fortifications here.
Following this will be this
campaign in the [? Voz ?] area.
It was a really rugged campaign.
Clausewitz says it
almost kills him.
He's only 12, 13 years
old when this is going on.
There are two other
officer cadets
in the unit that
are young like him.
They both are killed.
They both die as a result of
the rigors of the campaign.
And he almost dies as
well at a couple places
when the position he's
in one time is overrun.
But what does this tell
us, though, about him?
Well, it's important
for his development.
One, the experience
that he gets from this
always lives with him.
He refers to this later on,
the events that happens here.
But he also,
reflecting on it later,
he talks about just
how confused he was.
He never really knew what
was just physically going on.
But also intellectually,
he didn't understand,
why are we here?
What are we doing?
What is the point
of all of this?
Why is this war being fought?
And that puzzled
him, and he really
wanted to know and
understand these things.
And after this-- now, he never
had any education growing up,
or very little education.
Just some of the local school.
When you go into
the army at age 11,
you haven't had much
time for graduate school.
So he's posted on a village
family and a peasant family
for a little while.
And here's a library nearby,
and he begins to read.
And he discovers
the Enlightenment,
discovers education, and
becomes a voracious reader.
He's posted to
another command where
the commander of
the base he's at
is very much interested in
the education of his officers
and his men and even of
the men's families as well.
And he has a garrison
school and so on.
And here he really falls
in love with learning
and really starts
to blossom here,
and gets himself an
appointment to one
of the officer
schools in Berlin.
And this becomes
a pivotal thing,
as far as his development
for his career,
but also in why we get "On War."
Because here in Berlin, he
graduates first from his class,
and he ends up with a
mentor named Scharnhorst,
who is this gentleman here--
Gerhard von Scharnhorst who
runs the school.
And Clausewitz is
his star pupil.
Scharnhorst, he
teaches Clausewitz
how to think in many ways,
which is what is critical.
Scharnhorst very much
believed in critical analysis,
where you look at
something ruthlessly,
cut away the stuff
that's not true,
cut away the stuff that
doesn't make sense.
And when you look
at past events,
you try to get
solid history on it.
Understand what was
really going on.
Don't let your own deceptions
and perceptions confuse you.
Try to get at what is the truth.
And Scharnhorst also gets
him his next job as well as
an adjutant to one of
the Prussian princes.
And through that, he
meets this woman here,
a lady named Marie von
Bruhl who will eventually
become his wife.
She's a very intelligent,
articulate woman.
Very well read.
Very much his
intellectual equal.
From a much more distinguished
family then Clausewitz.
Marie's mother--
widowed mother--
is not so approving
of the relationship.
It actually takes
them seven years
to wear Madame von Bruhl
down to where she'll actually
agree to let them get married.
Because she's like,
oh, this young officer
without any land or maybe-- does
he have much career prospects?
She's kind of skeptical.
As a father of a daughter,
I kind of understand.
Who's your daughter
going to marry here?
But also at the same
time, he begins to write.
And this is important as well.
So we're already starting to see
when he's 23, 24 years old what
we're going to eventually
see partially in "On War."
Now in 1806, Clausewitz will
march off to his second war.
Why does this matter?
Well, Clausewitz has
become very ambitious,
and he's in a country--
Prussia-- where being a soldier
matters.
This is important.
And he is a soldier.
What matters to be
a successful soldier
is to prove yourself, to
have success in warfare.
And in his view, this
is the way that he
can make it for himself.
He says something along the
lines of my country needs war
and I do too.
So ambition is driving
him here for this.
What you have happen
in 1806 is essentially
where Napoleon, who is the
master of most of Europe,
he invades the
country of Prussia.
And you end up with this
two-pronged invasion of Prussia
by the French that is met
by two Prussian armies.
They will fight two
battles, Jena and Auerstedt.
The French will decisively
win both of these battles.
And they will win the
war because of it.
Now Clausewitz will fight at the
Battle of Auerstedt right here.
And his unit is the
rear guard, meaning
the Prussians had essentially
already lost the battle.
The unit he is in is committed
as part of the rear guard.
And they fight their way
into this city of Poppel
and then fight their way out.
And his boss, Prince August,
is wounded three times-- likely
wounded three times
in this attack-- which
was a glimpse of the intensity
of what is going on here.
And then what you
have after this
is a 14-day fighting retreat
where you can see from the map
here.
Roughly, Clausewitz's unit
follows this blue line
essentially, and
eventually they're
forced to surrender near
the city of Prenzlau
after a three-hour firefight.
And Prussia essentially
comes apart during this.
And Clausewitz is
shipped off to France
as a prisoner of war
with Prince August.
And now when Americans,
for most of us today,
if we think anything
about prisoners of war,
we think about Andersonville,
or we think about Stalag 17,
or maybe Stalag 13
if you're watching
old "Hogan's Heroes" reruns.
But we don't think
about the experience
that he has as an officer
and an officer that
serves an aristocrat.
They're posted to a
village outside Paris.
They spend a couple
weeks in Paris.
They go to Switzerland
and hang out
in Madame de Stael's salon,
one of the famous intellectuals
of the day.
Go visit the glacier.
You know, it's very much
a gilded imprisonment,
to say the least.
He hates every minute of
it and complains about it
all the time, because the
war is still going on.
He's missing a chance to
make a name for himself.
When the war is over,
he's sent back to Prussia.
And here he gets involved in
the Prussian Reform Movement.
And what this is,
briefly, is Prussia
was shattered by this war.
Prussia before the war,
Prussia after the war.
The French essentially
take half their country.
The Prussians know they've got
to change how they do things.
They've got to tap into
this nationalist sentiment
that the French had tapped into.
They've got to make the
Prussian people more
supportive of the
Prussian state,
give them an interest
in the state.
They've got to reform the army.
They've got to reform
the government.
Clausewitz is very
heavily involved in this.
He also becomes the
instructor of what
becomes their war college.
And he also begins to write
as well during this period
and starts developing some of
the ideas that will eventually
show up in "On War."
But also, he sees
by 1812 the way
the political winds are blowing.
And he sees that
Prussia is forced
into an alliance with France.
France is about
to invade Russia.
Clausewitz doesn't want
to participate in anything
under the French flag.
He hates Napoleon.
He admires Napoleon's
military skill,
but he hates him politically.
And he doesn't want
anything to do with this.
He thinks that Prussia
should rise up and fight.
And so he writes just
gigantic political declaration
which boils down to a cry,
in many ways, of violence,
to rise up and fight
against France.
But also, he says
some not nice things
about a lot of the ruling
elites in the Prussia
political system, which
wins him a lot of enemies
and a lot of bad blood.
And eventually, he just
resigns from the army
in the midst of all of this--
from the Prussian army.
And a lot of other
officers do as well,
because there are a
lot of other officers--
well, a few dozen others--
that feel the same way.
And what he will do now is
go to his next war, the 1812
invasion of Russia.
If anyone knows anything
about the Napoleonic period,
they usually have heard
of this and usually
know something about this
campaign, where essentially
Napoleon tries to defeat the
Russians in order to-- it would
make him master of
Europe essentially
if he does this, at
least of the continent.
Clausewitz is involved
in this campaign
from the first day it starts
to the very bitter end of it.
And it's just a gruesome
bloodletting the entire time.
And everyone knows about how
bad the winter is on the troops
here, but the summer is
also pretty grueling on it.
Essentially, you have
a French invasion,
and the Russians retreat in the
face of the French invasion.
Clausewitz initially is on
one of the extended versions
of the czar's staff
through his connections
with various officers
and politicians,
but he doesn't want to do this.
He wants to have a posting
where he'll see some action,
because, again,
here's the ambition.
He wants to make a
name from himself.
He says, I'm going to Russia
to make a name for myself.
I can't do it on the staff.
And so he ends up fighting in
several rear guard actions,
because that's where you can
make a name for yourself.
So he gets posted
to the rear guard.
Eventually, he will participate
in the Battle of Borodino.
As the French
advance, the Russians
decide, well, here's where
we have to fight them,
see if we can stop them.
And he's fortunate in
this battle in the sense
that he misses the worst
of the bloodletting of it.
And you can see, it's
about 130,000 men involved.
You have 65,000 casualties.
It's a serious slug fest.
You have French troops
attacking Russian positions.
Clausewitz is involved
in the cavalry attack
that the Russians launch, try
to launch on this flank here,
and they have a firefight with
some French and Croatian troops
here.
Essentially, the Russians
fight them to a standstill.
They begin their retreat
toward Moscow again.
Clausewitz goes back
to the rear guard.
Has a horse shot out from under
him in one action on the way
to Moscow.
He sees the famous
burning of Moscow.
He's in one of the last
units that go through that.
And after this, he gets himself
posted to yet another unit.
They're constantly shuffling him
around from different places.
He's supposed to go work in this
unit called the Russo-German
Legion as one of the
staff officers for that.
It's a unit that
the Russians were
forming from German exiles like
him and from prisoners of war.
They were doing it
for political reasons.
But the unit is not
put together yet.
So he doesn't want
to sit around,
and so he gets
himself posted to work
for a man named Wittgenstein.
Now, what is happened here?
This is one the other famous
events of the Russian invasion,
Napoleon's crossing
of the Berezina.
It's well known for just
the harshness of the weather
and the messiness of it,
the causalities of it,
and very much the destruction
of Napoleon's army.
What the Russians
try to do-- they
have an army under Wittgenstein,
an army under Kutuzov,
an army under Chichagov,
which I'm sure
I'm mispronouncing
that one, and they're
trying to catch Napoleon's army.
Napoleon fights his way
through them and gets away.
But the destruction here at
the crossing of the river
is enormous.
And you can see
from-- I'm not going
to read the letter for
you, but Clausewitz
experiences very much this.
But also in the wake of this,
as the French are retreating,
he will get the opportunity to
make a very significant impact
on warfare during the Napoleonic
period or the shape of it,
but not in the way he wants.
He wants to make
a name for himself
as a soldier, as
a combat soldier,
make a name for
himself in the field.
Again, he's very ambitious.
But what will happen is as the
French and their other ally
troops are retreating
from Russia, the unit
that Clausewitz is
in will make contact
with the Prussian
Expeditionary Corps.
Now, you remember,
the Prussians had
been forced to ally with
France to invade Russia.
But the Prussians
had been forced
to commit an army to
help them do this.
As Napoleon is retreating,
the Prussian troops
are also retreating in a
different part of Russia.
Clausewitz's unit comes
in contact with this.
He worked for this man
here named Diebitsch.
And Diebitsch says,
hey, talk to them
and see if you can get
them to change sides.
And the other Russians had
been trying to do this.
Clausewitz talks to
them and after a couple
days of conversations--
and there's certainly
some willingness.
A lot of the Prussians didn't
want to be here anyway.
They agree to change sides
essentially in the war.
And this is a pivotal thing
for the Napoleonic period
because it shifts the
alliance structure
in what is going on here.
This is a thing, arguably,
that in his military career
that Clausewitz
accomplishes that
is the most important thing,
because what you will have
happen on the tail
of this is you
will have yet
Clausewitz's next war.
And this is a gigantic
campaign in 1813 and 1814
with an armistice
in the middle, which
is a campaign that
will eventually
lead to the first
overthrow of Napoleon.
Clausewitz, he tries to get
back in the Prussian army.
The king isn't real happy
with what he's done.
And the king tells
him essentially,
well, fight in this campaign.
We'll see how you do and then
we'll talk about it afterwards.
So he gets himself detailed
to his old friend Scharnhorst
here, who is
essentially the chief
of staff for the
Prussian army here.
And so he goes to the staff
as a Russian liaison officer.
So technically, he's
still in the Russian army,
but he's back with
all the people
that he knew from before.
And he will help fight
in this campaign.
And he will also help
plan this campaign.
And one of the places
where he will fight
is the Battle of Lutzen here,
which it's a real slugfest.
Napoleon, the French
commander, defeats
the Russian-Prussian army
that comes against him.
Clausewitz calls this the most
memorable day of his life.
And he says this, I think,
one, because the intensity
of the battle.
The sides were so mixed in, and
the Prussians and the Russians
were-- essentially,
the entire staff,
which normally would
not have participated--
is also fighting hand-to-hand
at times in this battle.
And Clausewitz is hit
on the side of the head
with a bayonet in
what was probably
a cavalry charge against
a French infantry
square, certainly a
French infantry unit.
That would make
it memorable to me
if I'd been hit on the
head with a bayonet.
So what you will see
after the armistice
is a gigantic campaign
that the Austrians, who
enter the war, the
Prussians, and the Russians
will then launch
through central Germany
and into France
that will eventually
lead to Napoleon's downfall.
But to Clausewitz, this is kind
of a disappointing campaign
in a couple senses.
One, the primary campaign
is through central Germany
and into France.
He is posted up here into the
northern part of Germany--
here's the city
Hamburg, province
of Mecklenburg--
through what is very
much a peripheral
part of the war.
He's very upset by this.
He tries to get this reversed.
He doesn't.
They won't let him back
into the Prussian army,
so he's still technically
in the Russian army.
So he's put in this
multinational force fighting
in northern Germany.
The coalition warfare
here is extremely
complex and confusing.
You have so many different
countries involved in it.
But to boil it down, what
has happened is this man
here was a former
French marshal,
a very important officer
in the French army--
a man named Bernadotte.
He becomes the Crown
Prince of Sweden.
The other countries-- the
Prussians, the Russians,
the Austrians-- want him to
bring Sweden into the war.
He says, OK, I'll bring Sweden
into the war against Napoleon.
I want Norway.
OK, you can have Norway.
Well, Norway belongs to Denmark.
OK, so we have to invade
Denmark for you to get Norway.
This is the way
business is done.
They trade countries around
like they're poker chips.
And so Clausewitz ends
up in this army that's
Bernadotte's army,
but he ends up
working for this man named
Walmoden in Walmoden's corps.
Walmoden's corps is one of
the-- and some of the units
in it are the oddest units.
He's got Russians and
Prussians and various Germans.
The unit that Clausewitz is
technically a part of-- I
looked at their
roster-- it's supposed
to be the Russo-German legion.
It's got some Germans in it.
It's got some Russians in it.
It's got Frenchman,
Italians, Poles, and even
found a couple of Americans
listed on the roster.
So obviously not what it was
originally intended to be.
But why does this
campaign matter
here is the most
important thing.
Well, again, one,
Clausewitz was ambitious.
He wants to make a
name for himself.
How do you make a
name for yourself
in the peripheral theater?
He's very much angered by that.
But what will happen here is
they will fight a campaign
through here into the
northern part of Germany
and southern part of Denmark.
And there will be
a battle here--
a tiny battle for the Napoleonic
period-- in a town called
[? Zeistet ?].
And here what happens
is Clausewitz's unit
is surprised by the
Danish army, and the Danes
kick them around pretty hard.
And after this is what
matters, because this
worries Clausewitz.
Yes, they were defeated and it's
bad and the casualties are bad.
But there are two things that
come out of it that matters.
One, this is a defeat.
This injures their
reputation of their corps.
And he worries how this is
going to affect his future
and the embarrassment
this causes.
Defeat is not good.
Secondly, one of the things
he writes after the battle,
he writes one of his letters.
He says, the
intelligence we had all
said the Danes weren't there.
Now in "On War," he's
very critical in parts
of his book on war
about intelligence.
He's very skeptical about it.
Now, can you draw
a direct connection
between this one event and that?
I would say it would be
very difficult to do.
I would say it's more of an
example of his experience,
because so much of the time he
is the chief of staff officer.
He's the guy handling
the intelligence.
So I think some of it is that.
They finish up this campaign
in Holland and Belgium.
Not a lot dramatic
happens after this.
And Napoleon is deposed.
But then Clausewitz goes
to yet his fifth war.
And Napoleon escapes,
comes back to France,
becomes emperor of France
again for a short time.
The various countries
he was at war
with before mobilize
against him.
And what you will see is one of
the other most famous campaigns
of the Napoleonic period,
the Waterloo campaign.
And Clausewitz does not fight in
the Battle of Waterloo itself,
but he fights in a
couple of other places
during the campaign.
One in the Battle of Ligny here.
He is chief of staff
for Thielmann corps,
3rd Corps of the Prussian army.
He's back in the Prussian army.
They finally let him back in.
And so he fights in
this Battle of Ligny.
His unit is not committed
very heavily there.
They're mostly
used as a reserve.
But when the Prussian army
is defeated here by Napoleon
and comes apart, he has
this harrowing retreat
where he's almost
overrun by French cavalry
and they have to march all
night through the rain.
But then right
after this, they'll
fight the Battle of Wavre.
Now why does Wavre matter?
Well, here you have Waterloo
where Napoleon is defeated.
Here you have the
Battle of Wavre.
This battle matters for
a couple of reasons.
One, because they
tied down a lot
of the troops, a whole
corps that Napoleon
could have had in
support at Waterloo.
And if he'd had those
men at Waterloo,
maybe then the battle
goes differently.
Maybe not, but maybe it does.
And this sort of critical.
For Clausewitz, it's the
worst night of his life.
And they fight a two-day battle
here against a superior force.
They're defeated here
and forced to retreat.
And Clausewitz's
wife writes later
about why he thought
this was such a bad day.
Well, in his mind, why it was
the worst night of his life
because he knows
now he's not going
to get the chance to ever get
the military glory that he
wants.
He's not going to have
it, because they've
learned during their
battle that Napoleon
has been some severely defeated.
They know, yes, the war will
go on for a few more weeks,
but the conclusion's pretty
foregone at this point.
Now, what happens after this?
1815, Napoleon is deposed.
Clausewitz will have a couple
of jobs in the Prussian army
after this.
But in 1818, he goes to be the
director of the Prussian War
College.
And this is primarily
an administrative job,
and so it gives
him time to write.
He's always been writing during
this period-- history, theory,
politics, even stuff on
art and architecture.
In 1816, he begins to
write "On War," which
is what he's most famous for.
And 1818, he will really
start seriously pursuing it.
And he will work
on it until 1830,
when he boxes it up and
then takes up a new command.
And then eventually
he'll go and watch
the Polish revolt in 1831.
He won't publish the
book before he dies.
His wife will
publish it afterward.
And so we might not have it
if it wasn't for her efforts
to put it together with
some friends to publish it
and some of his other works.
Now, why does "On War" matter?
Well, "On War" matters
because of the influence
that it has in the way that
people think about war.
And it's not a book that
tells you how to fight a war.
It's a book that tells you
how to think about fighting
a war and things you should
consider and things that matter
and what the reality
of war he is.
He's trying to make
us develop, arguably,
a system for analysis.
So what I'm going to talk about
here just very, very briefly,
a couple of things
about "On War."
I'm going to cherry pick
some things, obviously,
because it's a very large book.
To Clausewitz, theory was
really very important--
having a theory, a method
for approaching things.
It clarified things
in your mind.
It put you on a foundation
for what you want to do,
a level playing field.
I think CS Lewis said-- I
think he said understanding
the terms of your argument,
knowing where that is makes you
better able to understand what
you're actually talking about.
And to him, theory, though,
has to be realistic-- not
hairsplitting, not
flights of fancy.
It has to be based on
reality, based on experience,
based upon history,
particularly military theory.
It's not something you just
make up with this ethereal idea.
It has to be something useful.
And to train the mind.
Now, one of things
he does in the book,
he's trying to set up
to explain what war is.
Well, what is it?
And you could get
different views.
Obviously, for him, force
is an inherent part of it.
To think of anything less than
this is delusional in his mind.
But it's not a
science in his view.
It's an art.
It's an art because there are
these things you can't measure.
These intangibles-- the will,
the spirit, courage, and so on.
But there are scientific things
that obviously intervene--
how many men do you
need, how much are they
going to eat, how far
can you move them,
what is the ammunition going
to cost you, and so on.
So there are various things
where they're hard numbers,
but how this all works together.
Obviously, complex.
You could make an argument that
war is the most complex things
that people do--
except maybe marriage.
That might trump
it a little bit.
But it's certainly
pretty close to being
the best or most complex.
It's a political act.
Bob mentioned earlier the
famous quote from Clausewitz,
"War is nothing but the
continuation of policy
with other means or
politics by other means,"
the political tool.
And one of the things
that some people argue
that separates Clausewitz's
theory from others
is the fact that how much
the role of politics--
it penetrates his theory
and is shot through it.
And it helps to explain
what he is thinking about.
Because to Clausewitz,
war and reality--
its influence is determined
by these various things.
The political
factors always go on,
the politics always go
on, even while you're
fighting, the human nature, the
moral force, the intangibles we
talked about-- chance,
uncertainty, friction,
the uncontrollable factors.
The enemy gets a vote
on what's going on.
He calls war a true chameleon.
So what would
Clausewitz say about how
do you think about fighting a
war-- what do you think about,
what do you do before you're
getting into this thing?
And he would say,
well, really, you
have to understand the
nature of it first.
He said the leadership has
to get this in their mind
before they do anything.
What kind of war is it?
What is the war about?
It's nice and easy
to say-- understand
the nature of the war.
OK, what in the
world does that mean?
Well, how do you do that?
There's one paragraph
here from Clausewitz.
He says, "To discover how
much of our resources must be
mobilized for war, we must
first examine our own political
aim"-- or objective--
"and that of the enemy.
We must gauge the
strength and situation
of the opposing state.
We must gauge the character
and abilities of its government
and people, and do the
same in regard to our own.
Finally, we must evaluate
the political sympathies
of other states and the effect
the war may have on them.
To assess these things and all
the ramifications and diversity
is plainly a colossal task."
I put this one
particular paragraph up
because to me, just in this
one little section, is so much.
That if countries
or planners that
are thinking about
getting into a war,
just examining these
things can give you so much
of a clue potentially
as to what can happen
and what you're going to need
to do to fight the war-- knowing
what you want, figuring out
how you're going to get it,
and how it's going to affect
other nations, as well.
Now, how else do
you to determine
the nature of the war?
Well, in his mind, first
be clear in his mind what
he intends to achieve--
your political objective.
Get that first, then figure out
how you're going to conduct it.
Because in Clausewitz's
mind, understanding
what you want-- everything else
is going to flow from that.
Rationally, it should.
It may not necessarily.
But ideally it should.
It should flow from that.
If there's anybody that has
read any similar things,
you hear the word
"objectives" or "aims,"
but you hear the term
"ends and means."
What you want-- what is the
end that you're hoping to get?
Do you have the means to get it?
Can you get to that point
that you're trying to get to?
Is it worth it?
Is it worth what we're going
to pay in blood, treasure,
prestige, and so on?
Do you have the power to get it?
If you do, well, use the
force necessary to get it.
Do what is necessary
to get the job done.
So again, the political
object for him--
how it determines all
of these other things.
He talks about what he calls
the value of the object.
He says, "Since war is not
an act of senseless passion
but is controlled by
its political object,
the value of the object must
determine the sacrifices to be
made for it in magnitude
and also in duration.
Once the expenditure
effort exceeds
the value of the
political object,
the object must be renounced
and peace must follow."
In other words, when
countries go to war,
they have things they want.
They will only pay
so much for it--
in blood, treasure,
other things.
Once one side is
unwilling to pay,
he argues that-- again, you
don't have to agree with him--
but he argues somebody will
make a deal at that point.
Now, he says also, well,
we know our object.
What kind of object do we
have, or political objective
do we have?
To Clausewitz, wars are
divided into two types.
There's a war fought
for regime change--
to overthrow the enemy regime.
And then every other
reason less than that.
In his view, wars fall
under these two types.
Now also, if you
read the book, he
will put forward this
concept of absolute war.
And this is confusing
sometimes for people.
And it leads to a
lot of the criticism
that you get of Clausewitz.
We're saying, oh, he says
everything has to be used
and war must be fought
at an absolute sense.
He actually says-- he uses this
as a theoretical construct.
He puts up the idea
of the absolute
and says war can't
really be waged this way.
Meaning, you're not
going to use everything,
and everything is
not going to work,
because reality intervenes.
People don't always do
what they should do.
Friction keeps you
from doing what you do.
You don't have the
intelligence you want.
It's uncertain, and so on.
So he uses a theoretical
concept to explain
what war is really like.
So we've got our objective
and we know the value of it.
But the paragraph I showed
you, which is essentially
an assessment-- how
do you figure out
the nature of the enemy,
the character of the enemy,
his abilities, his
military strength?
Well, he puts forward some
tools, arguably one of them
that would be useful for this.
It is called his "paradoxical"
or "wondrous trinity,"
depending which
translation you use.
And he says, "As
a total phenomenon
its dominant
tendencies always make
war a paradoxical
trinity-- composed
of primordial violence,
hatred, and enmity, which
are to be regarded as a blind
natural force, of the play
of chance and probability within
which the creative spirit is
free to roam, and of its
element of subordination,
as an instrument
of policy, which
makes it subject
to reason alone.
The first of these aspects
mainly concerns the people--"
violence-- back to the
French Revolution--
primordial violence.
Passion-- you want the
passion of the people
to help you fight the war.
"The second, the
commander and his army"--
the creative spirit is free to
roam, chance and probability.
War is the realm of chance,
the realm of probability.
The army and its leaders have
to be able to manage this.
And "third, the government"--
instrument of policy.
In other words,
the assumption is
that the government goes to
war for rational reasons.
Either it's forced to
defend the country,
or if fighting an
offensive war, then it
has a good reason for doing it.
It's not doing this just
because it wants to.
So it's these three forces--
violence, creativity,
rationality-- the people,
the government, the army.
But he says, well,
sometimes it doesn't really
work this way, because
sometimes governments
will go to war for
passionate reasons.
They will not
really think clearly
about what they're doing and
not have a clear objective.
So you look at
the strengths, you
look at the society-- the
military, the government,
and so on.
Then you say, well, where
am I going to land my blows?
Where is my force going
to be put against?
And he puts forth this concept
of the center of gravity
and essentially
argues that countries
have elements of power--
elements of national power--
certain key strengths.
And in his view, these-- the
army, the capital, the allies,
the leader, public
opinion-- it depends
on various different
things, which
one matters-- that one
or all of these things
will be key sources of
strength of a nation.
And ideally, you should
go after these if you can.
The reality is
sometimes you can't.
And also, with Clausewitz,
these are things you should do,
he will say.
But you always
have an exception.
There's always an exception
to any of his rules.
You say, well,
ideally, yes, you want
to go after the
center of gravity.
But sometimes,
there's an opportunity
that is so great
and so beneficial
that you go after that as well.
There's some other
objective worth pursuing.
So you know where you're
landing your blow,
you're fighting your war.
How do you end the war?
Well, he says, ultimately,
you really want to make sure
you are getting what you want.
You're preserving your state.
You're trying to get
ultimately a peace treaty that
will resolve the conflict.
And you have a settlement
that hopefully you
can live with that you've
paid an acceptable cost for.
But ideally, that's what
you want-- final victory.
But how do you get to that
ends up being the question.
You have to keep that in mind.
What do you do militarily
to get to this point?
And again, with so much of
things like this, it depends.
It depends on the situation.
There's no just template
for fighting any war.
How do you get there?
You might destroy
the enemy's forces,
you might take his territory,
you might occupy parts of him,
you might do something else
that will bring him around
to your point of view.
But what you're
also hoping to get
is eventually a settlement
that is lasting.
But he says the reality
is a lot of countries
and a lot of leaders, yes,
they will make a deal with you,
but they don't
intend to keep it.
For them, he calls a
"transitory evil," as he says.
I think this is certainly drawn
from his study of history,
and some from his experience
in the Napoleonic wars, where
the wars are fought
maybe a year or two.
And then you take a break.
And then maybe a couple years
later, you fight it again.
So in 1831, Clausewitz will die
as a result of the big cholera
epidemic that sweeps
through Europe.
His wife, along
with some friends,
will publish "On War" and a
lot of his other works as well.
And it is generally--
not always certainly,
but is generally-- considered
the best theoretical work
on war, the best
military theory on war.
There are obviously things
you can argue with it.
Again, some things that
some would say are obsolete.
But with it, he gives
us a good method
for thinking about
war, for doing analysis
and trying to figure out
what we're doing and why.
But there are, of course,
other books of theory as well.
It's certainly not the only one.
Well, thank you very much.
And I'll take any
questions you might have.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Is there
anything Clausewitz
has to say that you find
has become particularly
relevant in current conflicts
or with current technology?
DONALD STOKER: With the
technology, I don't know.
But with the current
conflicts, just
really having a clear idea
in your mind what you want
and why you're sending
people there to get it.
Knowing that and then
saying, is it worth it?
Particularly really knowing
what you want, I think,
is always relevant.
Because if you
know what you want,
then that arguably should
spark some thought.
AUDIENCE: So it
would be fair to say
he was critical
of mission creep?
DONALD STOKER: Critical would
be the wrong word, I think,
to say.
Because the reality
would be sometimes
the mission will change because
sometimes the circumstances
will change.
But if you know what
you want going in,
then maybe you don't
get the mission creep.
But then the
circumstance will change.
Maybe you're forced
to have mission creep.
AUDIENCE: I know it was
kind of early for this,
but with all of his
interest in theory,
do you know if Clausewitz
did anything with war games
or laying stuff out on
tables, that sort of thing?
DONALD STOKER:
Honestly, I don't know.
He participated in a lot of
real maneuvers in real wars,
but I honestly
don't know on that.
I never caught that anywhere.
But he did like
counterfactual studies,
where here's a problem.
Let's think about
the various ways
we can approach this problem.
And here is the solution.
Well, one of things he said,
if someone sets out their plan
and you criticize it, you
better have a better option.
If you're just criticizing and
you don't have a better choice,
then who cares what you say?
You've got to wonder about that.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
how he saw the ongoing conflict
in Europe as a way of making
a career and a fact of life.
But does he ever talk
about the morality of it?
Say, if he saw where today the
Swedes and Danes are no longer
fighting, attacking each
other for territory,
would he be disappointed to hear
they're no longer doing that?
Would he see it
as an improvement?
Does he ever talk about
the morality of it?
DONALD STOKER: The book
is really-- to them,
war is man's natural
state in many ways.
And you could argue
almost that if you
look at the certainly the
shape of European history,
it's sadly that way.
The book is a non-moral
approach to war.
He certainly understood the
reality of it but to him,
this is the reality of it.
As far as what he would
say about today, honestly
I don't know.
I think he would be-- like
what I mentioned related
to his question,
I think, the lack
of clarity about what people
want would always confuse him.
But he would say the same
thing about his own people.
He criticizes his own
government for not knowing
what it wants and criticizes
them for their behavior
afterward in some
wars, and gets himself
in trouble sometimes doing it.
AUDIENCE: It's a
two-part question.
So the first is,
why do you think
Clausewitz's work has
been so influential?
And second, what are some of
the real-world applications
of that?
Like, where in history have
we seen his influence really
has shaped events?
DONALD STOKER: As
far as why, I haven't
read most of the other
primary theoretical works.
And we teach some others.
We teach Mahan.
We teach Sun Tzu.
We teach Corbett's "Principles
of Maritime Strategy,"
which there are no boats
in Clausewitz's world.
But the others are
certainly useful.
His, to me-- and others would
disagree, certainly-- to me,
it gives a clarity of thought
and a systemization of thought
which is useful.
And plus he does give
us-- one of the reasons we
use it to teach with, it gives
us terms to define things
and it gives us
tools for analysis.
When we're teaching one of our
case studies and we'll say, OK,
what is the American
center of gravity?
And this gives us certain things
that we could look at and say,
we know what center
of gravities are.
How do we look at the strengths
or weaknesses of an enemy?
It's very useful for that.
As far as your second
question-- I'm sorry,
what was your second
question again?
You'll have to repeat it to me.
AUDIENCE: Where do we see
real-world applications?
DONALD STOKER:
Clausewitz's influence
was actually slow to develop.
There just wasn't that
much interest in it
for a very long time.
People started taking
more of an interest in it
after the
Franco-Prussian War, 1870
to '71, where the Prussians
come out successful in that.
And you see a general,
then, spread of his ideas.
It was fairly
influential with Lenin.
He liked the idea that
war is a political tool.
He said, this is clever.
You see it with some
American foreign policy,
but only after Vietnam.
And you see it particularly
in the Reagan administration.
There's an argument over
how you use military force.
You've certainly got the
post-Vietnam hangover
about that and you
have certain groups
of the administration that
are more hawkish than others.
Some want to intervene
in places, some don't.
And you end up with
Caspar Weinberger.
He develops this
Weinberger Doctrine, which
is some elements based upon
Clausewitz's teachings, where
having a clear
political objective,
understand the end you want,
understand the means you want,
make sure you have the support
of the people to do this.
If the people aren't
supportive of it
and the government isn't
supportive of this,
then we should
really be questioning
whether we're doing this
and whether it's worth it.
That's the best examples
of the influence of it.
I think it's had more influence
among military thinking
and analysis than
among politicians.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could say something
about how Clausewitz's "On War"
compares with say, Sun Tzu's
"Art of War" or [INAUDIBLE].
What are the points of sharpest
similarity or sharpest contrast
between the other books?
DONALD STOKER: Actually, when we
teach our theorist case study,
we use Clausewitz and
Sun Tzu at the same time.
And so we can get some
back and forth with them.
One of the things that's
very similar to them
is both of them
understanding-- look,
figure out what you're
getting yourself into here.
Clausewitz says,
look, war is violence.
People are going to die.
It's going to be expensive.
And it's going to be messy.
Understand that
before you go in.
It better be worth it to you.
Sun Tzu says the same thing.
He has a passage where
he tells the king,
he says, look,
when you go to war,
it's going to cost you this.
You've got to raise
an army like this.
People are going
to be mad at you.
It's going to be
expensive and messy.
Get this through
your head beforehand,
it better be worth it.
When Clausewitz talks about
his centers of gravity,
Sun Tzu has his priorities
of attack, and some of them
are exactly the same.
He talks about hitting their
allies, he talks about cities,
but he warns against it.
So there's a lot of
similarities to that.
Sun Tzu is much more in tune
with intelligence and deception
and Clausewitz is not--
he's a little more
skeptical of that than Sun Tzu.
But they are really
fun to study together,
because you get here's what
it's similar to, but also
here's where they disagree.
AUDIENCE: I think I have
the last question, myself.
Take an example--
it's in the news
right now-- Vladimir Putin
just got humiliated at the G20
and sent home for his
Ukrainian adventures.
What do you think his
objective really is in Ukraine?
DONALD STOKER: I was
in New York last week,
and I was involved in a
piece of a conversation
with other people with that.
And they were having an argument
about that, back and forth.
Both the people
were very informed,
so I don't know who
to believe on it.
What are his objectives?
Probably all of
Ukraine, a lot of people
would say-- at least
the parts of the Ukraine
that would allow him a
land bridge to the Crimea
and connect to Moldava-- that's
another opinion that I've
heard.
Another opinion
that I've heard is
that not only
Ukraine, but Belarus.
Ukraine's the first
step in Belarus.
And also there's a lot
of fear, apparently--
and this is my opinion,
and from what I've heard,
not the government--
there's a lot
of fear among prominent figures
in the Baltic states about what
might be-- the big cyber-attack
they launched in the Estonians
a couple years ago
and the kidnapping
of the Estonian officer.
And there's been a shifting
of all the Polish defense
forces around.
But basically, to look on
the border with Ukraine.
But I don't know what he wants.
I'm not a Russian
expert, by far.
BOB: Let's thank Dr.
Stoker for coming here.
[APPLAUSE]